[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
peter schrager the popular co-host nfl
network's good morning football
foxsports.com senior national writer
and uh he is uh on good morning football
here's monday through friday at 7 00 a.m
eastern also this week working with the
browns and broncos uh that'll be a
thursday night football for uh fox
amazon prime in the nfl network peter
joining us on the program pete uh the
possibility of derek henry winning the
mvp is what
strong national spotlight game i think
he needed that he's been doing it he's
on pace to have one of the greatest
running back seasons ever and that's
with a 16 game season or a 17 game
season but last night was big
a lot of times with the mvp and with
these voting it's what you do on monday
and sunday night when the entire country
is watching and you get that oh okay the
numbers are there he's throwing his team
on his back they're four and two i think
they're going to win that division
pretty handedly
if they can stay healthy enough to win
that division and he can break all these
records and it looks like he's on pace
to do i think he's going to be
considered in the conversation which is
so fascinating because i don't know if
there's another running back in the
league who's even in a conversation at
the top 20 in the mvp right now
when you look at emmitt smith's all-time
rushing record
do you think that there's a running back
um
i don't know if it's it that that's a
record that's breakable but if you're
going to try to handicap a running back
and today's game
is derek henry
you know the last that we'll see that
could come close to something like that
i think so and we try to throw their
names out like this off season it was
like actually nick chubb might be alvin
camaro without breeze but and like it's
just not like that mccaffrey can't stay
healthy these other guys aren't in the
same conversation henry does it year
after year after year after year
i i said today on good morning football
if he doesn't take another snap his
entire nfl career he has a hall of fame
argument to be made he's won the russian
title twice he's carried his team to the
playoffs twice he's had big playoff
moments in baltimore in new england
and what he's doing this season might be
his coup de gras so i don't think there
will be another one like him just the
way these offenses are built and just
the way that he's built i you know
nashee harris was the first running back
taken in this year's nfl draft he's a
nice player he's gonna have a great nfl
career is he ever gonna be derek henry
no i don't know if anyone will just the
way that they use him and the way that
he gets better and better as the seasons
go on yeah but i don't know so you're
saying derek henry has a hall of fame
resume right now if his career ended
i think so he's the best of his
generation i think if you write the
history of the nfl who was the best in
his generation
adrian peterson's going to the hall of
fame yeah who's the next one you can't
just say there's not going to be a
running back for 15 years and he's the
guy
it's gonna be a nice four-year window
five-year window in nfl history where
he's gonna be first-team all-pro every
year
i can make the argument that if he never
takes a snap he's in the conversation
does he get in i don't know
if terrell davis gets in with six
seasons of great numbers and what derek
henry's doing is eclipsing all of that
except for the super bowl rings of
course i think there's a conversation to
be had for derek henry in the hall of
fame i was wondering about lamar jackson
because he doesn't have a running back
that maybe he is more valuable to his
team than any other player right now
your thoughts on that
absolutely and what lamar is doing this
year he's doing it he's skinning the cat
a little differently than 2019 he's
throwing more he's making plays without
that great running back duo behind him
which at that year was obviously mark
ingram and justice hill and all those
guys that were there with him it is the
lamar show on offense and he's doing it
without nick boyle his top tight end who
blocks for him and with a bunch of
receivers who have not really elevated
their games yet uh to me right now the
mvp it changes week to week a week
whatever right now if i was to cast my
vote
i would have a very hard time deciding
between derek henry lamar jackson and
i'm gonna throw a third name in here
that might get a big hoot from the from
the danettes i think derek carr is in
the conversation derek carr is having an
outstanding season they're four and two
and
if this team can do this without john
gruden as head coach and with them not
missing a beat and getting the best out
of this team it's going to be because of
derek carr i would keep an eye on derek
carr there's going to be a lot of people
watching these raiders over the next few
weeks and if they don't combust wait
hold on hold on that's went away
yeah uh i i can't put derek carr in
front of kyler murray
you can't do it no no i can't
i think you need a nap
i've been up for a lot of hours i think
kyler's
kyler 6-0 he's in the conversation and i
you know i wouldn't argue if he was the
mvp right now but i right now with all
the stuff that he's got going on with
d-hop and aj green and that great
defense and jj
i think that's a collective effort right
now what derek carr is doing in las
vegas with the burden that he'll have on
his shoulders moving forward with the
head coach being replaced in the fashion
that he was i think they're they're i
love doing this this is classic uh
sports radio there's an argument that
can be made without me saying he is the
mvp
uh
the bill's getting off the hook here
with what happened last night you know
they
they i think a lot of everybody thought
they were going to win this game i was
one of them yeah um
is there a bit of hubris with this
bill's team that they beat the chiefs
and they're like all right it's done
let's call it a season yeah we're good
they look good last night the defense
though got some humble pie i think we
were riding high on that bill's defense
off of shutouts against you know teams
like miami and teams like houston and
then beating up on washington with which
we've seen but i thought that chiefs
game was like a major moment in this
bill's franchise history like we're
gonna quit figuratively and literally
like leap over the chiefs which they did
and josh allen had that jump and then to
fall the very next week
with all the people saying the bills are
the best team in football the second you
finally crown the bills
they have this loss where
the titans were all sorts of banged up
the titans they were down 10 late and
they still found a way to win it's not a
good one for the bills they certainly
don't walk away going into the bye
saying oh i feel great about buffalo and
yet their upcoming opponents jaguars
dolphins jets colts they'll be fine he's
peter schrager co-host of nfl networks
good morning football
um you start to look at contenders and
those who are not contenders the lions
dan campbell called out jared goff says
he's going to shake things up it's a
team that's winless you've got goff
going back to the rams could you see
jared goff being benched for that game
because nobody knows jared goff the way
the rams know jared goff
could you see
dan campbell making a quarterbacking
change going into that game this weekend
i made the uh i made the joke on good
morning football it's like
when brady went back to new england you
know the folks at nbc did the adele
video what are you doing with jared goff
going back to l.a like can we have
something for it
um it's the opposite of hello it might
be goodbye uh no he's he's gonna play i
i'd be shocked if campbell did anything
i think that was a little bit of a
rattle your cage but i watched that
whole press conference there were about
10 questions about goff in which he was
supporting him supporting but finally he
relented he's like yes he needs to step
up but everyone needs to step up the
talent deficiency on that roster
compared to other teams in the league is
is vast i'm not making any excuses for
jared goff he's never won a game without
mcveigh it would be great for him to
shock the world and get one here but
he's not likely going to do that it's
going to be a rough season for the lions
i think they knew that
i don't know if i'm all for and i can't
control a man's emotions but when you
cry on the podium in week five
and then the team loses 27 to nothing at
home to the bengals the following week
you've got to pace yourself now okay so
now dan campbell it's week six we're
going into week seven i would imagine
they get blown out against the rams
that's going to be stafford looking to
make a statement
how do you handle the next 10 weeks and
i want to see what kind of fortitude not
only golf but the head coach has to get
through this thing because
you could cry once you can maybe cry
twice
three times that then you might lose the
team with that kind of stuff so we'll
see he's a ball of emotion the coach the
quarterback is going through it right
now would love to see them fight in this
game on sunday i'm just not sure i see
it uh it feels like uh everything's good
with jacksonville they gotta win
nobody's talking about urban meyer right
is he has he kind of uh
survived the storm here there was some
other news last week and i think
everyone looked at the urban meyer
situation and said all right we're
moving on to a different topic and
i say that flippantly it was a terrible
week for the nfl it was a horrific week
for the nfl but jacksonville they got
out of town well that was all going on
in our network and on your network and
everyone was dealing with the fallout of
what was a chilling chilling few days
jacksonville left the country urban
meyer news kind of faded to the
background and they focused on winning a
football game that they probably had no
right winning at the end there there
were some defensive questions on miami
and then the jaguar stole one there and
now they come back
and it's like okay let's get above water
we got the buy let's come out of this
thing and we'll see what we can do
um but i don't think anyone's calling
for urban meyer's head right now and i
certainly
uh don't think that that that franchise
is collapsing by any means under urban
meyer whether it would happen in
columbus ohio or not aaron rodgers with
his shout out to the bears fans it's
almost like it felt like aaron was
playing the role of victim like you guys
yelled at me and uh flipped me off and
i'm gonna yell back at you what do you
make of aaron rodgers owning the chicago
bears comment it was something huh i get
that as like his like fail his farewell
moment you know that was like his walk
off i don't think he's gonna necessarily
play in that building as a division
rival moving forward so that was kind of
maybe his last one but what was funny
was kyle brant in our show was like you
know it might be a straw man i don't
know if anyone actually was giving him
the middle finger and then we got a
thousand tweets from bears from packers
fans of like a million bears fans giving
him the middle finger like yes no they
were
absolutely
um
i guess he got caught up in the emotion
of that thing i i have no problem with
it and i don't love that kind of stuff a
lot of times but the nature of that
history of that rivalry and the respect
that he has shown uh some of those bears
players over the years whether it be
erlacker or peanut or lance briggs
earlier in the week saying those guys
should be hall of famers uh i i kind of
liked it it was such a play it was such
a moment it was raw emotion something we
don't always get from these guys
yeah um the other topic that i found
interesting and and you know how this
goes pete it goes week to week where
jimmy johnson says hey i would take uh
justin herbert over uh patrick mahomes
on the fox pregame show
it opened the door for everybody to go
i'd take justin herbert over pat i go
what what just happened what did what
what happened like all of a sudden
everybody has decided that they're off
the patrick mahomes bandwagon then he
throws a couple of pics against
washington you know the vitriol there
you know twitter just like yep you know
he's washed oh my god they're stuck with
that contract now with patrick that was
the craziest one all the contract
experts came out of the woodwork on
twitter they're like look at what
they're stuck with almost making this
argument that like they would they would
undo that contract if they could and i i
shouldn't be so dismissive of it because
they have been really sloppy this year
and he's you know got eight
interceptions he had six all last year
and some of these interceptions are not
on him and his mother will tell you that
over twitter and some of them are
um but then something happened with
about three minutes left in the third
quarter he has that touchdown to tyrique
and if you watch the fine i know it's
the red it's washington but if you watch
the final 18 minutes of that game it
looked like the chiefs of old and they
just absolutely lit it up they went from
having 10 points to finishing with 31.
mahomes could not be stopped tyree kill
and kelsey did whatever they wanted and
it was like a little taste of like don't
don't count us out just yet and in the
same week where
we see the chargers get humbled a bit we
see the bills get humbled a bit
chiefs are right behind them they're
three and three and they're lurking it's
the last team i would want to face in
the playoffs especially that quarterback
rams are the chargers all in
rams
rams there's a pressure for the rams
this year that it's like this is why we
are trading future first round picks
this is why we went out and got this guy
anything short of that run is a letdown
for the chargers i think this is a bit
of a house money year you've got a young
quarterback on a rookie contract and a
first year head coach they make the
playoffs that's a great season for the
charters i don't think anyone's talking
actual super bowl right now maybe they
get there
but the rams i think it would be a
disappointment if they didn't make that
game
but imagine what a super bowl would do
for matthew stafford's career
yeah like matt ryan at least has an mvp
yeah
and he had the appearance in the super
bowl
and what it would do uh moving forward
that's two years in a row that a team
said screw it let's go get the guy
like let's go get the guy whoever it may
be let's go make a way to happen next
year i think there's going to be a lot
of conversations about russell wilson it
all stems from your very show last year
but it did give a little window into
russell's mindset and aaron rodgers and
deshaun watson
go get the guy it works that's what
tampa bay did and that is what the rams
did and they were significantly better
right out of the gates because of an
upgrade at the most important position i
think a would help redefine his career
obviously and it would redefine the way
we look at at matthew stafford's entire
13 years in the nfl but it would also
redefine the way you look at an
offseason yes built through the draft
but if you can go get your guy at
quarterback go get him okay more likely
to be on a different team next year
russell wilson or aaron rodgers
i think aaron rodgers i think aaron
rodgers i think
just the way that thing just kind of we
limped into the regular season with one
of these deals we're like all right
let's see what happens
i don't know how this ends up for either
one of these guys and
i know mike florio's big on the hey if
russell was upset last year with what
they did he's certainly going to be
upset this year with what's going on uh
i just think it's a little trickier with
the contract with russell and with
rogers there is an exit plan and there's
jordan love and there's
almost a wedding of the appetite with
the packers fan base that hey this might
be the last ride the russell thing would
be a really abrupt change for seattle
yeah i don't think ross ends his career
there i don't know
i i would be surprised if he's there
next year really surprised you would say
you over 50 chance you'd say it's a
greater chance he's not there now well
let's say they don't make the playoffs
yeah
i i don't know at some point russ wants
to russ is looking at his legacy
i think you have to go back to that you
know a couple of days after the super
bowl when he came on he saw brady still
being brady and he saw patrick mahomes
in the super bowl and probably says
what about me like he he's now thinking
bigger picture what's my legacy going to
be he's not winning anything in seattle
and i think everybody brady opened
everybody's eyes to quarterback
empowerment and i think that's where
russ said i want to have a say i want to
be able to say who we're going to draft
or bring in what aaron rodgers wanted to
have a say deshaun watson wanted to have
a say i think russ just said hey is
anybody going to listen to me that's why
i think he was shouting from the
mountaintops when he came on i don't
think anything's gotten anything's
different you know same head coach same
gm same philosophy i just get feeling
russ is going to go
i i got to win another championship here
i've only got one i want i want to be
one of the greats of all time
he's got two of the best receivers in
the sport he's got an offensive
coordinator that he helped hand pick and
he is mr seattle if he stays there
forever i mean that is his city forever
and it's great i know
but they're not going to win
it's going to be tough and when you give
jamal adams all that money and you trade
your next two first-round picks for a
safety it doesn't help russell wilson's
cause in any way of saying hey we got
this much better this off season uh
thursday night it's uh browns in the
broncos on that note
uh
got injuries everybody's got injuries
how much pressure is on baker mayfield
this year
a ton and it's the contract extension
looming because where do you peg them
would you give him a contract extension
would you give him 45 million a year i
would wait i would wait to see what we
get this season okay if you're if you're
missing the playoffs and baker's out
there then what are we getting for that
money and maybe it's time to move on but
like the jets knew they weren't doing
anything with sam darnold they ripped
the band-aid off they said let's get
something for him the browns i think a
lot of people thought they would sign
them to a deal similar to josh allen
after last year's playoff run or you
know but they haven't so they're waiting
they're seeing how this thing plays out
and i think thursday night if he plays
it's tough as tough as nails for him to
play but
gosh it's a long season i don't think
it's the craziest thing to say hey let
keenum have one here on the short week
and then i'll get back in afterwards
we'll see how it plays out though yeah
you're supposed to build up the hype for
thursday night football do or die both
these teams i think that's good i don't
need baker out there give me a team
that's playing for everything both these
teams have hit the skids the last few
weeks they need it how's that for
hunting okay now i'm watching now i'm
gonna watch that game case keenum teddy
bridgewater case kingdom revenge game
okay
yeah but there's a few of those case has
been on a few teams
uh thank you pete save travels this week
always great to catch up with you great
catching up and one name for you an nba
player paul millsap annette i had no
idea
thank you peter
paul millsap